the packers way to go kirk cousins seven
and two yep
still pushing forward panthers came to
town i thought the packers would blow
out the panthers especially once i saw
the snow flying i got to give the
panthers credit for hanging around it
was 24 to 10. the panthers made it 24-16
went for two didn't get it but still
down eight driving late
and
i think christian mccaffrey scored i
just think
we couldn't see the ball right i know we
couldn't see the ball in part because of
the snow but all the angles that were
available there's an angle from one side
where there's a receiver who's standing
in the way and you can't really see
whether or not the ball got across you
just can never see
with that kind see right there the
ball's in no he's not no no no the
ball's in watch watch christian
mccaffrey
but look at his body yeah look at his
body the ball is right next to his right
hand he's not in if he extended which
you know he's being careful here because
he he doesn't want to fumble but i don't
know you can't even really
but he never extended i i think that's
the biggest thing to me right like right
there look the other guy you could see
turner's left shoulder is on the white
line he's not to the left shoulders all
right
it was a good idea
but look the bottom line is there wasn't
clear and obvious evidence no there was
that ball got in it looked to me like
the way the bodies were positioned he
got across but unless you can actually
see the ball at least kissing the front
end of the line they're not going to
overturn that right that's one of the
flaws in the process you have to get a
good shot of it and sometimes you just
don't get a good shot of it there's
nothing conclusive one way or the other
let me put it this way if they had
called it a touchdown there wouldn't
have been enough there to overprobably
not no that would have been tough tough
to see you're right there was nothing
conclusive at all it was a great game to
watch either way just because of the
snow it's green bay packers it's lambeau
field that's always got a great look on
tv uh man there's so many different ways
this game could have gone you know the
end of the first half you're going wow
they have this horrible penalty on
gerald mccoy the packers drive all the
way down to the one yard line don't
score before their first half you're
going oh man they're gonna score before
the half's over and get the ball back in
the second half and this is going to be
a blowout as to what you're talking
about but carolina makes the stop hangs
around then sonic gets momentum back and
you know another big point of the game
was kyle allen down in the in the red
zone there you know he kind of moves up
in the pocket scrambles throws an
interception in the back of the end zone
as he kind of stares a receiver down
there and uh that that saved green bay
whose offense kind of sputtered out
towards the end of the football game i
still think green bay is a little pass
happy at times i mean you look at the
results they had in the run game
yesterday aaron jones 13 for 93. you
know jamal williams 13 for 63. you know
when i see those type of numbers i just
go no they're not getting the ball
enough they need to get them more uh
but green bay of course is very good i
don't think they're great you know
they're one of those teams where yeah
they're seven and two
but i don't think they're in the class
of the 49ers
or the new england patriots at this
point i think there's some concerns for
me at least with their team overall
especially their defense and we'll see
what they do down the stretch you know
can they hold on they don't have an easy
road the rest of the way and i mentioned
that monday night game coming up
december 23 at minnesota who knows the
the division may be riding on that one
by the time it's all said done it's just
so weird to see these early highlights
from lambeau yeah if you're watching on
tv this is the bad cough first off
what's gerald mccoy supposed to do here
he's falling to the side he doesn't fall
on him but this is later on in the drive
here they are driving down we have
rogers you think is going to throw a
touchdown pass here throws a great ball
jimmy grant steps on his own feet
doesn't get two feet in which was
originally called a touchdown right mike
so now they got first and goal from the
two yard line
bam jared mccoy makes up for that stupid
penalty they called on him anyways and
that was a huge moment for the panthers
team to give them some momentum going
into halftime and aaron jones with the
three touchdown performance after the
game aaron rodgers touting him as an mvp
candidate and i think that's a little
too much when you look game by game yeah
aaron jones has had pockets of great
games he has not had the kind of wire to
wire dominance that you need to be in
the mvp conversation especially when
you're not a quarterback but aaron jones
has been a critical member of that team
and he's stepped up on days when the
packers have needed it and they're going
to need it moving forward they have next
week off then they are at san francisco
that's one of the games of the week week
12. there's some great games lurking
week 12. then they go to face the giants
in new york they have washington at home
those are all winnable games the bears
come to town but it's at the vikings and
at the lions to end the season where
things can get very interesting for the
packers i mean they could go into the
last two weeks of the season holding a
buy right and end up
as a wild card team because they could
get caught by the vikings one week sure
in the standings and then the next week
go to detroit and that's never an easy
place for aaron rodgers and company to
win so the packers have a lot of work to
do and like you said there are some
flaws there and uh they they held on
they got the win and the panthers still
would have had to convert the two-point
conversion and then the panthers would
have had to win in overtime who knows
what would have happened but the
panthers they need to be proud of how
they've played without cam newton and
and the other thing too it came out over
the weekend cam newton's now thinking
about having foot surgery which would
mean he definitely wouldn't be back even
if the panthers somehow make it to the
playoffs it's all pointing toward next
march will he be healthy who's he gonna
play for and even in a loss yesterday
that's one of those games where if
you're the panthers
maybe you're not all that uncomfortable
right sticking with kyle allen yeah and
letting him be the guy at least for 2020
to see where it goes and then you make
decisions after
next season depending upon i think if
allen keeps playing the way he did
yesterday i mean other than that one
mistake he did a lot of good things in
that game avoided pressure made a lot of
big throws and he is he's going to give
them something to think about and they
got west virginia great will greer oh
yes right right yes what i don't see it
i don't know
second rated quarterback in the drought
well then maybe maybe maybe they're
right maybe you're wrong no they were
wrong we're going to take a break when
we're returning though i was talking
about my rankings too
are you done you got anything else you
want to complain about that was just
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports